when i tell nice guys you need to make
yourself your number one priority in
life they get a deer in the headlight
looks oh no that'll make me a bad person
that'll make me like my father or all
those jerks i've heard women complain
about but no the a true sign of maturity
in fact i think the number one
characteristics of a mature adult is a
person who takes full responsibility for
both their actions and their needs and
their wants now we can't get all of our
needs and wants met by ourselves and we
can get a good start at it we can get up
and drink water and do some exercise and
do some meditation we can do a lot of
things to nurture ourselves but we need
a lot of people around us we need a
posse i call these cooperative
reciprocal relationships we need a lot
of both friends professionals practices
different things that fill our bucket
from there we can give from the overflow
[Music]
what's up guys welcome to the michaela
peterson podcast this is episode number
105 and i'm hosting dr robert glover
yes
this was a doozy of an episode a doozy
he's a marriage and family therapist
although he mostly focuses on coaching
men
he's the author of the best-selling book
no more mr nice guy we had some very
interesting topics to cover
we talked about what the issues are with
being a nice guy or nice girl for that
matter we talked about his experience
learning how to be compassionate but not
resentful discussed his book
relationship advice expressing inner
emotions as men
and women for that matter
and more it was a good one if you
enjoyed the episode with adam lane smith
on relationships you'll love this one dr
robert glover is a really smart guy
i hope you enjoy this episode if you do
please don't forget to subscribe
[Music]
dr robert glover welcome to my podcast
how good to be here
i've heard of the book no more mr nice
guy
for years and years and years
and i'm very excited to get you on here
i think i had one of my other guests
tell me about you although i'd heard of
your book
so i think my audience is very
interested in this
so
i'm excited to be here and actually i
just have to say that i i yesterday i
listened to a few of your previous
podcasts just to get a flavor and i
listened to a previous guest who
mentioned my name and i thought wow that
that was kind of nice
when he dropped the g-bomb on me i
thought i don't hear that very often but
it was nice so that's weirdly
coincidental yeah it's just weird well
you know he he was talking about
relationships and i'm all about
relationships so i thought i'll listen
to that that podcast and um okay fair
enough that was adam lane smith
okay well yep he's the one who told me
to get you on and so now you're here
before we get started could you give
just a brief background about who you
are and what you do for anyone who
doesn't know who you are or what you do
yeah i'm um
that's a good question i my background
is that my um
my training in uh is in marriage and
family therapy i was a marriage and
family therapist for a number of years
in private practice
and about close to 30 years ago while i
was struggling through my own second
marriage
um
basically my second wife said you need
to go get some help or i'm leaving you
and i thought i was a nice guy you know
i was treating her well treated her
better than her ex was raising your kids
and so um i
decided okay i'll go figure out what she
means what i'm saying which says i'm
passionate aggressive or i'm this or i'm
that
and i had a phd in marriage and family
therapy and didn't even know what
passive aggressiveness was so i i joined
a 12-step group got into a men's group
got into therapy and started realizing
that i had a internal life paradigm that
if i was a good guy if i treated
everybody well did everything right
people would love me like me i'd get my
needs met without having to ask
and um and realize that wasn't a very
effective life paradigm and so
in my counseling with other men and
women i started noticing a lot of guys
coming to me with their wives or
girlfriends saying the same things i was
saying i'm a nice guy i treat her better
than her ex i'm raising her kids i give
her everything she wants i try to make
her happy she's never happy she never
wants to have sex anymore
blah blah blah and i thought i can
finish these guys sentences for them so
25 plus years ago i started my first no
more mr nice guy men's group
and uh
soon added a second and i just started
writing little chapters to give to the
guys and they started saying robert you
should write a book you should go on
oprah and uh i kept writing and wrote a
book never got on oprah not yet um
but but i'm on the michaela peterson
show so you know that that's like i'm
there
so um
and so that's been about 25 years i've
been working with men i i no longer do
private practice i have an online
university i do workshops in seminars i
do some consultation
um i write books and i now live in
puerto vallarta mexico and
you know have a great life so that's
that's the nutshell of me and and
probably how i ended up being uh talking
to you today
okay so
what does what does a nice guy look like
like the wit the one that you write
about in your book
okay and i'll talk about specifically
nice guys but also
say that a lot of things i talk about a
lot of of your women listeners will
probably relate to as well because
there's been nice girls around forever
okay so it's the same it's the same
problem for men and women and it's at
his base it is it then manifests often
in a little bit different ways for men
and women but the base core paradigm is
a nice guy or a nice girl doesn't
believe they're okay just as they are
and you know we mentioned adam lane
smith and he did a really good job
talking about how children internalize
at a very young age
any negative painful experience as being
caused about them all all children are
very narcissistic they're the center of
their world
and so when something painful happens we
believe i must have caused that
which then turns into a grandiose belief
system that has two sides to it one is
that i'm so bad i cause people to leave
me hurt me cry be depressed drink yell
scream whatever
and if i am that powerful to cause that
i also must be powerful enough to
prevent that or fix it so there's these
grandiose beliefs that there's something
so bad with me that i caused people to
leave me or hurt me
and i must be powerful enough to prevent
that from ever happening so so nice guys
and nice girls basically then grow up
and by the way this belief system is
recorded at a very deep emotional part
of our brain uh it's recorded in our
amygdala where our emotional operating
system is so this isn't like words we
have it's not an intel
intellectualization it's not even like
visual memory it's just an emotional
belief system down in our operating
system that then affects every other
part of our brain and so we grow up to
be children adolescence adults with a
belief system
if i can just be good enough
and become what i think other people
want me to be
then i'll be liked and loved and get my
needs met and if i can hide anything
about me that might get a negative
response from other people then i'll
never get abandoned so
men and women both
that they if they have these nice guys
internalization or attachment issues as
as adam smith called them um
they might manifest differently for a
guy than they do for a woman but the
core belief system is the same is that
there's something wrong with me i'm not
good enough that's typically called
toxic shame i have to become something
different become what other people want
me to be and hide those whatever that
bad thing about me that i think is and
you for most nice guys what we tend to
hide is our needs our wants and our
sexuality so we we keep that all under
wraps so we don't get a negative
reaction from anybody
okay so would that kind of
would that kind of nice person arrive
from a childhood that was like overly
stressful
is that where it comes from or could it
be a regular childhood and then you end
up like that anyway you know the word
stressful is probably a really good
application because what happens and i
write about this in my book is when i
first started looking at nice guy
syndrome i was looking at me right so i
thought i'm a nice guy uh how did i
become a nice guy well it's probably
because i had this interaction with my f
this type of interaction with my father
this kind of interaction with my mother
i was brought up in a fundamental
christian church that had a lot of you
know hellfire and brimstone messages uh
just grew up in the 60s and 70s with
angry feminism
every man's a rapist an erection is a
sign of aggression and so i always got
internalized into my emotional brain
and i thought okay maybe all other nice
guys are just like me but i quickly came
to realize they weren't
there's a lot of different factors and
and the this you mentioned stress
however we might experience stress and a
lot of this has to do with temperament
because you can have two children born
into the same family with very different
temperaments and they handle the
stresses very differently and develop
different survival and defense
mechanisms so a lot for what i found
with nice guys and nice girls for many
it partly just do our next to our
natural temperament i'm a fairly easy
going
you know don't rock the boat want to
make everybody happy kind of guy it's my
basic temperament yeah yeah okay yeah so
that's part of who i am and then when
you add those stresses as you speak of
and those stresses would be anything
that's painful uncomfortable you know
you you went through a lot of painful
things as a child i had surgery at five
days old and i can just imagine
emotionally what that felt like to have
you know back then you know parents
didn't come to the waiting room it
wasn't nurturing and soft and you know i
probably would just take it away from my
parents put on a cold table put a mask
over my face and wake up in pain and you
know how does a child at five days old
internalize that information
it's not going to be done logically it's
done emotionally
and so
whatever those stresses might be it
might be you know our parents don't get
along well it might be
that
you know that they repress their
feelings it might be that sexuality is
repressed in the family it might be that
mom and dad fight a lot it might be our
you know or
maybe our father was never there it
could be any number of things
it could be that we were hungry and
didn't get fed quickly or we you know
wet our diaper and didn't get changed
quickly those kinds of things are the
stresses
that a child internalizes i've got to
find a way to not keep experiencing
these these painful experiences and all
children do this not just nice guys or
nice girls all children develop defense
survival mechanisms to try to do two
things number one cope with the
uncomfortable feelings they're feeling
in the moment so i sucked my thumb till
i was in kindergarten that was a coping
mechanism some children become needless
and wantless some cry some fight some
some please some smile all the time um
that's how we try to manage the
uncomfortable feelings the second thing
that we try to do is try to prevent the
things that cause these uncomfortable
feelings from happening again in the
future
now take all of that bundle of stuff
that we just talked about fast forward
that into adolescence and adulthood we
all have that emotional operating system
we formalized at a very immature
helpless dependent stage of life and we
assume that's the way the world works
and we go out into the world opera
functioning from that emotional
operating system and even if for example
we can't find any big trauma in our life
or our parents are still married and
have a have a good marriage
anything uncomfortable or painful
is stressful to a young dependent child
this episode is brought to you by
selfauthoring.com i thought that was
appropriate giving the episode
self-authoring was developed by my dad
over the last 30 years with help from
two other phds at mcgill and harvard the
self-authoring suite is a series of
online writing programs that
collectively help you explore your past
present and future
i seriously cannot tell you how
important it is to write out your
traumatic experiences in order to get
them out of your head hell you may end
up with a book like me writing has been
one of the ways i've stayed sane through
crazy amounts of stress diet too of
course of course
uh sometimes you need to wait though
before writing out trauma maybe even a
year so you don't re-traumatize yourself
by going over the experiences all over
again the present authoring program has
two modules the first helps you
understand and rectify your personality
faults
it literally identifies ways that you
suck and helps you plan to fix them it's
brutal
the second helps you understand and
develop your personality virtue so it
kind of makes up for the false part the
future authoring program helps you
envision a meaningful healthy and
productive future three to five years
down the road
and develop a detailed implementable
plan to make that future a reality use
code mp to get 10 off at self
authoring.com put your life together
make a plan stop being useless etc enjoy
the rest of this episode
what's the opposite of the mr nice guy
like if you don't if your coping
mechanism isn't to be
nice like you're explaining what's the
opposite that can happen
well what i could call in the book is i
call them an integrated male now there
could be any any number of names an
authentic male authentic authentic
person integrated person but basically
it's a person who's uh comfortable with
their own feelings they don't feel like
they need to hide anything about
themselves they're they're they're open
and visible and transparent uh they're
able to soothe their anxiety and take
action rather than trying to manage
their anxiety by medicating it away or
managing people in situations outside of
them
they're honest they'll tell you what
they think what they feel they want um
they're they're not pursuing external
validation or recognition they they're
self-validating uh through their own
actions through their own uh sense of
integrity um they're what the term
they're differentiated and the and
differentiation basically is the ability
to ask yourself what do i want what
feels right to me uh you know what was
my gut say and then to follow through on
that even when there's resistance either
between your own ears in terms of
neurotic guilt and anxiety guilt yeah
and or change back messages from the
people around you
that's a differentiated authentic person
that basically lives life on their terms
as a what you see what you get kind of
person can be open and available to
relationship can be giving and generous
but they're not giving to get they're
just giving as is needed rather than
what they need to get validation so
there's a lot of different features that
that would go with this more authentic
integrated person
okay so i'm probably more on the nice
spectrum than the authentic integrated
person okay i'm fairly i'm fairly
disagreeable but i think being sick as a
kid
and trying to avoid being depressed and
trying to avoid stress like just
stressful situations i'll do things like
try and manage situations so i i can see
where you're coming from
how do you know like isn't there a
isn't there part of
okay let me just give you an example let
me try and word this properly if you're
in a situation where you're trying to
take care of a family member
doesn't it sometimes benefit
to be the nice person okay or is that
just always not a good thing to do
because there's you know guilt wrapped
up in it like isn't there some point
where you kind of need those kind of
people yeah that's a good question and
and you found yourself in that place in
life i have as well probably we all do
it sometime here's the perspective of
that
is that
i don't use the word codependency in my
book and i did that on purpose mainly
because when i wrote the book 20
something 25 years ago the term
codependency was primarily only used
with women and with like family members
of alcoholics and and so i wanted to
talk about the dynamic of this giving to
get or covert contracts as i call it
without people getting a predetermined
idea of what code you know
projecting their own pre predece pre
idea of codependency
so
the the nice guys i talk about it
operates like i said from what i call
covert contracts is they're if then
propositions and there's three primary
covert contracts of nice guy syndrome
this be true for guys or girls
one is that if i'm a good person then
i'll be liked and loved
uh for most men that also manifest and
the women that i desire to have sex with
will want to have sex with me if i'm a
good guy
they'll want to be with me
second covert contract is that if i meet
everybody else's needs without them
having to ask then they will meet my
needs without me having to ask now as
you can imagine that that's not a very
functional way of relating to other
people
third covert contract of nice guy
syndrome is if i do everything right
then i'll have a smooth problem-free
life
and this is kind of a that's what gets
me i think yeah i do too i follow hey
hey i did everything right how come
you're upset at me you know you should
you should do nothing but make my life
easy and praise me and appreciate me i'm
the same way so
but it's a very immature peter panish oh
if i get everything right everything in
my life will work well but a couple
problems with that is nobody ever gets
everything right we're human we're we're
we're
we're flawed you know we're imperfect
and the other part of that is we don't
live in a smooth problem-free perfect
world we live in a chaotic world and in
accepting that the world is chaotic is
one step towards maturity because then
we quit trying to manage the chaos um
and so going back to your question then
if you are not operating from covert
contracts if you're not giving to get
and then the way i often put it if
you're not giving from an empty bucket
where most codependents nice guys nice
girls are because we're not good at
making our own needs a priority our
bucket's empty we give to others hoping
that they will then give back which
means that our bucket doesn't usually
get filled and we often have a lot of
guilt around taking good care of
ourselves or meeting our own needs or
making ourselves a priority when when i
tell nice guys you need to make yourself
your number one priority in life they
get a deer in the headlight looks oh no
that'll make me a bad person that'll
make me like my father or all those
jerks i've heard women complain about
but no the a true sign of maturity in
fact i think the number one
characteristics of a mature adult is a
person who takes full responsibility for
both their actions and their needs and
their wants now we can't get all of our
needs and wants met by ourselves and we
can get a good start at it we can get up
and drink water and do some exercise and
do some meditation we can do a lot of
things to nurture ourselves but we need
a lot of people around us we need a
posse i call these cooperative
reciprocal relationships we need a lot
of both friends professionals practices
different things that fill our bucket
from there we can give from the overflow
and we can we can be generous and we can
bless other people's lives and we can
give to them what they need to receive
not what we need to give
out of our covert contract coming from a
place of emptiness so to come back to
your question
if you are taking good care of you which
is essential if you're going to give to
anybody else if you're filling your own
bucket in a consistent way
that makes you feel loved and lovable
and then you can give from the overflow
with no strings attached no covert
contracts and give to people what they
most need to receive not what you most
need to give to get your covert
contracts met
so yeah you know i i think i heard you
mentioned you have a young child
yes okay scarlett she's she's almost
four okay so here's an example of what i
call two levels of differentiation
first level of differentiation is where
you ask yourself what what feels right
to me what do i want what is what do i
need what's important to me and then you
take action to to do that and again you
do it even when you experience the
resistance of neurotic guilt or change
back from the people around you
now there's a second level of
differentiation that can only occur
after you've
achieved first level differentiation and
then you can also ask what is in the
best interest of the people i love what
is in the best interest of the planet
that i live on right and and now from
that place you might actually make some
sacrifices you might actually put
yourself second in order to put somebody
you love first that needs to be
especially a child or uh an ill parent
my mother is 86 and had a stroke coming
up on three years ago she lives alone
she can still drive but she's fairly
disabled physically and you know i live
in mexico she lives in seattle i get up
there at least every other month and
people oh you go up to see your mom a
lot they go yeah i go up because she
lives alone you know she she doesn't
have a lot of social connections she
can't get out a lot
um i go make sure you know her during
covid you know her pantry is well
stocked and that she doesn't have to do
a costco run by herself and so
i can take care of my mother in
differentiated ways now as a child i
tried to take care of her in codependent
ways because i thought my my
my
ability to thrive and survive depended
on me sacrificing me to take care of her
i'm now a differentiated adult and i can
make sacrifices or i can go out of my
way to do things for her now with you
with your daughter
i remember my son's 36 when when they're
small you think they're never going to
grow up but you know i've got a
14 year old granddaughter now so they do
grow up pretty quickly and i remember
you know when he he was a baby that um
at times you know he he'd be up all
night and you know my my then wife would
come in and say i can't take it anymore
i can't handle it you've got to go be
with them and at that time i was a
minister and so like you know visit
saturday night i had to get up and
preach sunday morning and you know and
i'm thinking oh i don't want to go be
with a screaming baby i need my sleep i
got to be good in the morning
and but you know what i got up because
it was in the best interest of my my
then wife to let her not be with a
screaming baby when she was at her wit
sands and for me to go be with my son
and you know believe it or not some of
my fondest memories are of those years
when he was a baby
be in the rocking chair i'd be holding
him in my arms rocking talking to him
singing to him
and
i could give to him
because i was already taking good care
of me and we can make those sacrifices
to give to others if we're not all
sacrificing ourselves so fill our own
bucket and then give from the overflow
and at times we do put ourselves second
to make somebody else who needs
our attention number one
okay that totally makes sense so you can
end up doing
you can end up
well you end up being a better person
right if you're just giving and it's
making you resentful and angry and
isolated then you're not a nice person
really you just think you're a nice
person right you just do it and that's
actually that's that's a good point
because that's the way because like
people will say well how do i know if
i'm a nice guy how do i know if i'm
using covert contracts the way you
usually know it is that you feel
resentful and victimized you're not
being appreciated enough you're not
getting back as much as you give you're
not being noticed you're not being
thanked you're and if you if you're kind
of ruminating about those things and
feeling bitter and resentful and if that
starts manifesting in either passive
aggressive behavior which is i i cut i
actually did learn what passive
aggressiveness was you know when you
express your anger and indirect kind of
ways like instead of saying i'm mad at
you or i'd like you to do this or i'd
like you to stop we we poke at them we
jab at them we embarrass them in public
we shut down we don't follow through on
our commitments whatever those are
passive aggressive behaviors or nice
guys often can go into what i call a
victim puke where the stuff just builds
up builds up builds up until boom it you
know everything we've ever rehearsed in
our head that we wanted to say because
we're so respectful yeah just comes out
and and i remember um when i was doing
most of my work and when i wrote no more
mr nice guy i was in my second marriage
and uh i mean i had to learn a lot i i
had to grow up a lot and i remember i'd
have one of these victim pukes with with
my then second wife and um
she she you know when was all was said
and done she said like how long has it
been bothering you
i'd go i don't know six months maybe and
she go it never crossed your mind to say
something about it i go
no not really and really it hadn't it
never crossed my mind that maybe i could
say hey this bothers me or hey can you
do this different or hey can you stop
doing that or hey can we talk about this
it's just built and built and built
that's a pretty clear sign that you're a
nice girl or a nice guy that all these
things you do for other people actually
start taking a toll they start building
up in terms of resentments and perhaps
rage and frustrations and they get
manifest in those passive aggressive
ways or in the occasional victim puke
okay so say somebody's listening to this
and is realizing that they exhibit some
of these traits of uh overly nice person
what are the first steps in figuring out
how to i guess start expressing healthy
emotion
okay that's a good question and i'll
tell you how i started and and i found
that this seems to be
a pretty good starting place
and i i mentioned that i went to a
12-step group and i i didn't know where
else to go but my wife was telling me
you're a sex addict and so i thought
well i don't think so i'm not having
very much sex i'm not sure how you fall
but so i went to this 12-step group for
sex addiction and it was all men
and and it met like 6 a.m in the morning
and i i was in my early 30s at the time
and i went and i did quickly find out i
wasn't a sex addict but for the first
time in my life i had a safe place to
just open up and reveal me to talk about
me both my hurts my pains anything that
i repressed behaviors i'd never told
anybody about thoughts and impulses i
never told anybody about
and i actually got excited about getting
up once a week you know to be at this
meeting at six a.m in the morning to to
to just reveal me and talk about me
and soon or at right at that same time i
also got with a therapist that i started
working with maybe six months or so
later i got with into a men's group that
i was in for four or five years and i'm
still today in a men's program i've been
in for three years
and
the number one place to start is go find
a safe person or a safe place and start
revealing you now this does a few things
one it lets you start releasing that
internalized unconscious toxic shame
that that core belief that i'm i'm not
okay i'm not good enough now i found uh
this distinguished i found in nice guys
and so i'm sure it's true and nice girls
as well
there are two types of nice guys one is
the i call it i'm so good nice guy the
other is the i'm so bad nice guy i fit
now i'm so good nice guy category i
think i do everything so well everybody
should think i'm great now
deep down inside in this really dark
tightly locked box is my toxic shame
that i work really hard to avoid ever
having to feel or experience the sense
that i'm not okay that's why i work so
hard to be good is because deep inside i
don't feel okay that's the i'm so good
nice guy if everybody got to know me
everybody would love me now i'm so bad
nice guy who's often the guy that
started rebelling or acting out
oppositionally defiant behavior at a
young age maybe start drinking doing pot
dropped out of school you know [ __ ] up
a lot and then maybe you know got
married or had a kid or found jesus or
he got in the military and they got
their life in order but now they're
trying to be a nice guy but deep inside
they still think if anybody gets gets
close to me they're going to find out
how messed up i really am so that's i'm
so bad nice guy
so
by finding a safe person a coach a
therapist a group a 12-step program a
minister rabbi whatever
and beginning to reveal yourself you
begin to release toxic shame
and that that is so
so unburdening so liberating and you
start getting more accurate feedback
from a safe person is to who you really
are yeah
and you know you might say before i'll
give you an example i was leading a
men's workshop several years ago and
there's a guy in there
um
early 40s african-american
and he just carried so much toxic shame
and so during this workshop i just asked
him
what is your deepest
same shameful thing about you and he
told a story that when he was like 14 he
stole a car stereo
and because of that ever since he's just
believed he's the most terrible human
being and like all the other men in this
workshop looked at him it was a small
group at 8 10 guys and they said really
that's it
we all did stupid stuff when we were 14.
you know that that's that's like
probably small change and like he got
accurate information that doing a stupid
14 year old thing did not make him a
horrible person and that was that one
thing was just liberating to him that he
he could quit beating himself up for
being this terrible person so we get
more accurate feedback as to who we are
by by revealing ourselves to say people
we also get to practice being honest and
that was such a big thing for me nice
guys think well you know we're so great
we're so this we're so that you know we
you know give us a parade give us
confetti whatever but the truth is most
guys most nice guys are extremely
dishonest
we only reveal what what we think you
know you want to hear we hide anything
that might get the negative reaction we
we twist the truth we leave it out we
embellish it we misdirect your attention
and so one of the first things i
realized i had to do
was just start being an honest person so
being in a safe environment
let me practice telling my entire truth
with people that weren't going to like
overreact or abandon me
that then let me begin practicing it
with the people who i was most afraid of
overreacting or abandoning me
family partner
close friends
and so having that safe place lets us
release shame get more accurate
information of who we are and alyssa's
practice being a more honest person so
that is where i recommend people start
this is so interesting okay i'm very
glad i had you on i had a great time
with like adam lane smith smith i was
like this all makes sense that's so
interesting so this is very cool so
that's why uh al-anon
is such a huge thing right because you
connect with somebody and who cares if
like what's the risk of telling them
your deepest darkest secrets it's not
like your family right they're not
necessarily going to care
yeah and you know and i'll tell you a
short story um
when i was like early in this process i
i was in this 12-step group and i had a
therapist a female therapist
and um
pretty early on i i had a dark
sexual impulse i didn't act on it but
just the fact that i noticed myself
having this dark impulse really scared
me now the old previous me
probably never would have let that
impulse even get into conscious
awareness but when it did because i was
practicing letting stuff come into
conscious awareness
it scared me it scared me i didn't act
on it and that felt good but it felt bad
that i even could think something so
dark
and so i went to my 12-step group and
told them this dark impulse that i had
and you know the the only reaction you
ever get in a 12-step group is you know
thank you for sharing you know that
that's it you know nobody goes oh you're
a horrible human being how could you
even think of some you know it's just
thank you for sharing and and most of
the guys in this group their lives were
so freaking out of control they're
probably thinking that's it that's the
worst that's that's the worst you got to
bring to us so i told them and it was
such a relief to just speak it out loud
and just not carry it around inside of
me where eventually it would have either
kept fueling a lot of shame for having
the impulse or perhaps it might have
even gotten acted on right if i didn't
deal with it and bring it out in the
open so i went to my 12-step group told
them no big negative reaction so i
actually had a an appointment with my
therapist
like an hour after the group so i drove
over to her office and i'm thinking same
thing i'm going to tell this female
therapist this dark sexual impulse she's
going to think i'm a terrible human
being blah blah blah but i told her and
just you know i told her the impulse and
she just looked at me with compassion
and said well let's explore what that
story is about and like i'm going that's
it
that's as terrible of reaction as i'm
going to get so i get done with the
therapy session i'm driving home
my
my second wife i used to tell her that
her middle name ought to be overreact
because that's what she did in every
situation and so i'm driving home to to
miss overreact to tell i'm thinking i
gotta tell her i gotta tell her i you
know i think i already told my 12-step
group already told my therapist i'm
batting a thousand if i tell her and she
overreacts and has a terrible reaction
to it i'm still 666 great batting
average no problem
and so i'm driving home soothing myself
right and not rehearsing the story
because if i'm just going to tell her
the truth i just got to tell her the
truth
and um i get home and uh i say i got
something i got to talk with you about
took her back to the bedroom we sat on
the bed and i said um here's the thing i
said i want you know already talked to
my 12-step group or he talked to my
therapist
but the thing i want to tell you about
is i had this impulse i didn't act on it
but i had it i've talked about it i've
gotten it out i needed to tell you about
it
and she just looked at me and said
that kind of scares me
it doesn't surprise me
and i'm glad you told me
and she never brought it up again never
reacted never used it against me and i'm
sitting there thinking
this is like magic you know all you have
to do is just reveal just tell and and
you know it's when we're keeping the
secrets and hiding the things that
people sense something is wrong and out
of whack that's what most people are
reacting to is what what doesn't seem
true or aligned and me just sitting down
and saying here's the truth after having
already practiced that with safe people
let me then do it with somebody that i
did have fear that she might have a
negative reaction
and and i'm grateful that she didn't and
that because that helped reinforce i can
keep revealing myself and i can handle
whatever the reaction is that people
might have
yeah that's very interesting
i like that you pointed out it's
the the hidden things that create fear
that people are reacting to it's like
what are you not saying how bad could it
be and i guess if you shove something
down in yourself and you think it's that
bad you're gonna give off those i don't
know that energy that people around you
like look how bad a person i am
even if it's not necessarily that bad
yeah they and they do sense it i mean i
tell men that for example that um and i
found that women are especially
sensitive
to to this energy to repressed energy
they they get it that now i know a lot
of women will like then project what
they think it's about
but yeah oh guys i'll tell guys for
example let's say you're driving down
the street with with your girlfriend or
your wife or whatever and and you've got
gas and you don't you don't want to rip
one right there and so you're repressing
you're holding the gas back you're being
a good person a good citizen right by by
not ripping a fart you know while you're
driving down the road but you're
repressing something and not saying
anything about it your woman is sitting
there next to you going there's some up
there's something going on with it he's
holding something back he's repressing
something oh i know he was looking at
that woman's breasts on the corner back
there and he's still thinking about her
breasts he's thinking you know and then
the woman will create this big story and
all of a sudden they're having some big
fight because she'll accuse him of the
thing that she projected and he was just
trying to be a good guy and you know
holding hell and gas back and that goes
on all the time in relationships uh is
is one person holding back and the other
person sensing it
having some visceral reaction to it and
often creating a story to go with it
that's usually a projection of their own
personal story from their own past
experiences and now all of a sudden you
know they're often fighting about
something that didn't even happen but
something was happening that never got
spoken of it's the meta thing
most people never really fight about the
thing they're fighting about they're
fighting they're fighting about some
meta type thing but now they're talk
they're arguing about this but it's
usually something different than that
okay this is good i'm gonna get some
practical advice then um
what should
people who
uh let's do it for the parents say
you're a single mom or a single dad
um which is already like there's gonna
be some stress in that
how do you
help your kid to not develop this nice
guy syndrome
the best way i know to do that is
through modeling and and probably you're
aware of that that you you know if
you're yeah if your daughter sees you
doing certain things she'll probably
model it you know mostly they say for
example yes most most children that
smoke grow up seeing adults smoke or you
know most that develop drinking issues
saw adults not that's not always the
case but our children model our behavior
for good and for bad
so
if going back to what i was talking
about of you filling your own bucket up
for example
if your daughter sees you consciously
surrounding yourself with lots of
resources those cooperative reciprocal
relationships i was talking about
whereas you and your friends as you and
professionals that you have in your life
your doctor your dentist your
chiropractor your accountant your co you
know co-workers
and you are consciously
getting what you need to fill your
bucket from those resources as you also
give you and i right now have a
cooperative reciprocal relationship we
both agreed to be here we both assume
we'll get something of benefit out of
being here together and you know if
after we're said and done if either one
of us decided that wasn't worth the time
or investment we probably wouldn't do it
again but if both of us felt like hey
that was worthwhile that was beneficial
we would very definitely consider doing
that again that's what a cooperative
reciprocal relationship is so if your
daughter for example sees you
spending time with your girlfriends
exercising eating healthy meditating
going for walks in the park laughing
having fun
surrounding yourself with goodness
that fills your life fills your bucket
then you're giving to her from the
overflow and she will then model those
same behaviors
a good a good model for this is um a guy
named m scott peck wrote a book called
the road less traveled
uh it's probably 40 years old i've heard
it's the all-time best-selling self-help
book
and um there's a whole chapter in there
on discipline i'm a whole section holds
a section on love
and he says love i'm gonna paraphrase it
is the giving to oneself or to another
in a way that promotes one's or
another's spiritual growth now you could
also just say
well be okay
and he says and i teach this in a lot of
my programs he he has this really cool
model that i've expanded on he says if
the if the parents are meeting their
needs in in a timely judicious way
filling their own bucket up if they have
healthy differentiated relationship with
each other to where mom and dad aren't
in what i call an ownership fused
relationship which is you belong to me
therefore you should constantly fill my
bucket up because i feel so empty that's
how most of us do our intimate
relationships but if our partner is just
one more of our cooperative reciprocal
relationships just one of many
bucket fillers that we have in our life
and we're one for them as well both mom
and dad's buckets are going to be filled
and then peck says if the parents can
then
take the time to pay attention to each
of their child's needs and respond to
their needs in timely and judicious ways
and i add consistent to that list
because i think consistency is a real
important key so if you as a mom are
filling your own bucket you're
surrounded with good resources to keep
your bucket full to keep you energized
you can then pay attention to you'll
have time to pay attention to your
daughter you'll see what her own
particular needs are in any given moment
you'll give to them in timely ways
you'll give to her in judicious ways and
as i'm sure you've already found out
giving judiciously to our children
requires the wisdom of solomon you know
you know do you give your 11 year old
wait till she's it'll probably come
before 11. it'll probably happen at nine
maybe it's already happened she comes
home says mom i need an iphone you know
i you know i i need an ipad
yeah uh so i need an iphone and you know
your 11 year old doesn't need an iphone
because it's probably not good for her
to have an iphone but maybe every one of
her friends has an iphone and you don't
want her to feel left out and not apart
and oh what do you do with that i mean
those are
that seems like a not that important
decision but those are the important
decisions of judicious giving to your
children so so you if you're giving to
your child judiciously and consistently
peck says that a child internalizes at
the emotional level so we're going back
to talking about our emotional
internalization our emotional operating
system the child will internalize i am
important i'm lovable i'm valuable
that's number one number two my needs
are important and number three that the
world is like my family
now
if that doesn't happen if children don't
get their needs met in timely judicious
way they internalize the opposite i'm
not i'm not lovable valuable or
important my needs are not important and
the world is like my family so they're
going to go out into the world treating
interacting with the world like nobody's
going to love me or meet my needs unless
i like give to them first or you know
use whatever my survival mechanism is
but there's one more
internal belief system that children
develop if their parents are not doing a
very effective job of meeting their own
needs and then giving to the child in
time to judicious consistent ways often
a parent will use the child to come meet
some of their needs emotional needs
social needs needs for physical
connection and when a child is used to
meet a parent's need it's called
parentification
the child child will always believe
that they're not good enough because
remember children are
grandiose and narcissistic and
egotistical if mom is sad and leaning on
their child the child thinks i should
make mom not sad but because mom is sad
and sad in ways that a child can't fix
and continues to be sad the child
internalizes i'm not good enough i can't
make mom be not sad i can't make dad not
be angry so the child also develops that
fourth belief system i'm not good enough
and then goes out into the world and
interacts with the world thinking i'm
not valuable i'm not lovable my knees
aren't important and i'm not good enough
but going back to your question if
you've been consistently
judiciously timely meeting your
daughter's needs not perfectly by any
means but just you know shooting for you
know being good enough
your child will internalize the belief
system i'm valuable i'm important my
needs are important as i go out into the
worlds i go to preschools i go to
kindergarten as i go to school as i
start dating in junior highs i you know
on and on
i'm going to believe that i'm valuable
my needs are important and the world is
going to respond in kind
and i don't know about you but i i think
about that at times what would it have
been like to be in junior high thinking
i'm valuable i'm lovable my needs are
important and everybody else recognizes
that
i'm thinking how how powerful that would
be and so that's how you how we raise
our children to develop this
internalized system where they don't
have to be using their defense
mechanisms their survival mechanisms or
covert contracts now we're not going to
get it perfect none of us do we all had
imperfect parents we're going to be
imperfect parents we're going to raise
imperfect children and in fact giving
yourself permission to be an imperfect
parent and letting your child be an
imperfect child it's one of the greatest
gifts that you can give them because i
see a lot of parents nowadays wanting
their children to be perfect so they can
feel like perfect parents you know these
helicopter parents that go you're going
to study this you're going to go to this
camp in this camp in this camp you're
going to make these greats and you're
going to go to this kind of college you
know that helicopter parent that's a
burden on a child it doesn't let the
child differentiate and just be who they
are
maybe the child just wants to be an
artist or play music or travel the world
but no you're going to get into mit
you're going to get into stanford you're
going to make the good enough grades to
get that that that creates also that
belief in children that they're not good
enough and they've got to be perfect to
be loved
so letting your child be their imperfect
self is also a great gift to give your
child
okay so how about this
and i'm what i'm trying to do with
scarlet is exactly what you're saying
and so i've been you know interviewing
people and learning a lot and i've seen
a massive difference in our relationship
relationship in the last like year or
two so things are going really well but
just to play devil's advocate
if you raise your kid thinking and i'm
not going to be doing this but if you do
raise your kid and they end up thinking
they're not good enough
does that
lead to individuals who try and be
better and are more motivated and end up
being more successful
well it depends on our definition of
success because yes
not happy like maybe from the outside
looking successful yeah and that's a
good question and of course we can look
around and see that and maybe we see it
in ourselves is that yeah there's a part
of me that wants to
achieve a certain degree of success so
that you know i can feel good about
myself and people will value me and
there there's there's a difference and
and i think the difference is is you
just have to feel the difference
um for example i got a phd at 29 years
old
and i think i was motivated
number one i almost dropped out of high
school high school just bored me i was
just totally lost and unrested once i
quit playing sports i lost interest
and luckily i i i got with some really
good teachers i got into debate and and
got into some stuff that energized me
then all of a sudden you know studying
and making good grades
felt felt
just internal it felt interesting i
wanted to apply myself now
you could try to make grades trying to
get make good grades by trying to look
good or get approval or validation or by
time i got to college then and through
college and then to graduate high school
i maintained about a 3.8 grade point
average and i think there was some part
of me that was yeah look at me i made
these kind of grades but not not a very
big part of me most of it just was i can
do this this feels good and that's what
that's the difference of how it feels
and where i'm at in life right now i'm
65 years old most people start like
thinking about retiring at my age i have
no interest in retiring and i i don't
even know what that would look like i'd
still get them do what i do um and i i
got i got nothing else that i have to
prove to anybody or accomplish and so
i'm purely motivated by the love of
doing what i do
it just it just excites me i mean just
two experiences that you know before you
and i started your call your your
producer said robert i read your book it
was really powerful at an important time
in my life i said thank you for telling
me that that feels good right that that
that my ego isn't built on that but it
feel good knowing that i made a
difference and and it felt good when i
heard adam lane smith somebody that i
don't know personally say a really nice
thing about me on your podcast i thought
i i had to turn the podcast off and just
sit with it and just sit with it and
think
that that was so out of left field i
didn't see that coming and it just
because i didn't and i just thought wow
that felt really good now
i don't do what i do to try to keep
getting that you know those nice words
and nice things i do what i do because i
love what what i do and i'm glad that it
makes a difference and has an impact on
people's life so for example with you
and your daughter
you could try well i'm going to do this
and do this and then she'll be a happy
child and i'll i'll look like a good
parent and i'll you know blah blah blah
and that's that external validation kind
of thing that's driven from not feeling
good enough inside
but if you just enjoy
the experience of being a mother with
your daughter and just
love to death
just being a mom with her
then you're just going to be you it's
going to feel good it's going to feel
natural you're going to make mistakes
you're going to snap at her occasionally
you're gonna let her hear things you
didn't wish he didn't hear
but you know what it's okay because you
know you know you're open-hearted and
loving towards her it just feels
different than that feeling of my
child's got to get good grades she's got
to look good she's got a good impression
she's got to make me look like a good
mom it just feels different and and you
can just check inside to feel the
difference in it
yeah so you have to start being like
brutally honest about that underneath
all the
all the lies you've told yourself or the
stories you've been brought up with or
something feel like it's a good thing or
a bad thing and you can start that like
you said by starting to be honest with
people that
that if they respond negatively it
doesn't really matter in your life i
guess because then you're more open to
talking to them and i love the idea of
just being brutally honest with yourself
because that's where it has to start and
you know as i said i i've got a son i've
read step kids as well
my son's a a good kid and i'm proud of
him and i love him to death and um and i
can remember because both he and my
stepson were about the same age and
they're both really good in sports and i
love going to their games and being the
proud papa and i almost always make sure
the people around me know oh
a quarterback that's my son you know or
the guy that's hit the home run that's
my son and i'm thinking that that was me
um parentifying my child that was me in
a sense using my children to feel like a
good person now i'm human i did it and i
it wasn't a terrible thing but i'm also
honest with myself that that was that
was me parentifying my children that
that was
not letting them just be them for the
sake of being them and me being happy
for them right i was feeding off of it
in some kind of way okay we're all
probably we're all going to do some of
those kind of things and you know what
it's okay we're imperfect
but if we're brutally honest with
ourselves we notice ourselves doing it
and we go
i'm going to try not to do that in the
future because i don't think that's
probably the healthiest thing for my
child and and we work on it so it does
begin with being brutally honest with
ourselves
it's got to be tricky to figure out
exactly like where you're
coming from
when you're displaying some sort of
emotion because there are i mean there's
there's got to be couldn't you be
couldn't you have been saying the same
thing on the sidelines but it wouldn't
have been
terrifying that's what you said
yes and i'll go back to the difference
of the the two examples i gave of your
producer and adam lane smith
yeah i didn't go out seeking their
approval right i don't i don't know
either of them and they both said some
very kind things to me and about me
and and it felt good now i could then go
out and try to keep getting other people
to say those same kind of things about
me because it felt so good or i could
just soak it in and let it be there so
yes you can be proud of when your child
excels at something and just smile and
soak it in and go i'm so amazingly proud
of this human being that i call my child
okay
you again you notice the difference you
notice when i'm hoping this person next
to me knows that's my son out there
playing quarterback because then they'll
be impressed with me you know and i i've
done the same thing with my dogs you
know i've got a right now a one-year-old
pitbull and i just want everybody to
think i've just got the coolest dog and
it's the same kind of thing it's that
external validation i used to have a
weimaraner years ago same thing
everybody thought my dog was so cool i
loved walking down the street oh that's
a cool looking dog
and that's that external validation that
you can get addicted to right and we can
do that with our kids we do it with our
partner we can do it with our successes
in life oh look at the things that i've
accomplished you know
look at the car i'm driving look at the
house i live in look at the boat i have
and
it's great to have a great car it's
great to have a great house if you like
boats it's great to have a great boat
but do it because you love the car you
love driving the car you love driving
the boat you love living in your house
not because
look what i've attained look what are
people going to think of me you know
when i drive up in my great car in front
of this great house i mean that's a
never-ending addictive cycle
and um
you know it i think it all goes back
still to just filling our lives with
those cooperative reciprocal
relationships we're filling our own
bucket up which makes us feel loved and
valuable and that our needs are
important and then we don't need all the
external stuff to get some sense of
validation
do you think a lot of the reason that
marriages don't work is because people
don't have enough friendships as well
and they're looking for their partner
looking to their partner for
everything and it's just not possible
you teed that one up for me nicely thank
you um
i think there's a number of reasons
relationships don't work um
i'm not sure they're meant to work i'm
not sure they're part of our human
evolutionary dna to have pair bonded
lifelong intimate relationships with the
office oh that's interesting i i mean
our ancestors did not do that for a
million and a half years we've been
trying to do it for less than 10 000
years and it's never really worked real
well but that's why that's why we have
religion and a lot of rule systems to
say you have to do it uh and and if you
don't you're a failure uh kind of you
know shaming people into trying to make
it work so i don't believe that they
that they actually are meant to work in
the way we think that they are i mean
even the whole idea of romantic love i i
heard some time that you know that's
only been around about 200 years that
we're going to get with somebody because
we have them and then i heard that that
shakespeare wrote romeo and juliet to
show the extreme fallacy of romantic
love oh we love each other so much let's
kill ourselves you know it's it's silly
but
i do believe that relationships can be
powerful personal growth machines i say
that all the time if we approach them
consciously and realistically you know
if i get with my partner and think oh
because i think you're beautiful and
because i think your body's hot
therefore you're going to be an amazing
partner to me but we're in trouble right
or if you get with a guy because you
think oh man he's he's six foot two and
he's got a nice build and and you know
he makes a lot of money he'll make a
great partner no the things we base our
decisions on for getting with people
often you know i i tell i tell men all
the time so i mainly work with men now i
say you know everything your male brain
thinks that a woman can do for you is
wrong and i tell women the same thing
everything your female brain thinks a
man can do for you is wrong
but
if two conscious people are willing to
accept the challenges the difficulty of
trying to create an intimate pair bonded
relationship with a member of the
opposite sex with all of our baggage
from childhood with all of our
relationship fears with all of our
defense mechanisms with all of our
projection projections with all of
society's unrealistic expectations of
how they should work this as i said can
be a really powerful personal growth
machine so there's a lot of things that
cause relationships not to to go long
term one is that they're they're
probably just not meant to um number two
is that the the
unrealistic expectations we have of them
is another one how we be how we form
these relationships at least for me i'm
a terrible picker when it comes to
relationship i've bumbled my way through
every relationship i've got um i think
it was peanut melody who wrote a lot
about codependency i read this years ago
said that we tend to be attracted to and
marry a person who has some of the worst
traits of both of our parents
oh my god
yeah let that sink in that means
unconsciously we get attracted to people
that that are giving us the opportunity
to work out our dad issues and work out
our mom issues and that person picked us
because we're giving them the
opportunity to work out their dad issues
and their mom it's horrible and then we
expect that's going to work for a
lifetime and we're going to be happy the
entire lifetime okay but if we know that
if we can be conscious of those pieces
we can actually watch that stuff coming
up and and work with it especially if we
have help if we have you know coach
therapist good resources so back to your
question and it goes back to the whole
differentiation thing
i think this idea of this pair bonded
lifelong intimate relationship with a
member of the opposite sex
like i said it's only existed we've only
tried to do it for a few thousand years
and what does happen is that a lot of
people who are not filling their own
buckets up with a lot of cooperative
reciprocal relationships come into
relationship feeling needy we find
somebody we're attracted to is basically
come fill my bucket meet my needs now
what makes this even
what makes this worse is that when most
couples get together
they start giving up whatever they had
going on in their life that made them
who they were when they met
you know maybe they start demanding that
of each other well you need to quit
hanging around with your guy friends you
need to quit hanging around with your
your girlfriends or you know you need to
spend more time with me or you need to
not go out as much at night i i years
ago i knew somebody is actually um a
friend of a friend but when this couple
met the guy played on three softball
teams so he was playing softball all the
time they met dated he continued to play
softball they got married they got
married and his wife said now that we're
married you have to quit playing on so
many softball teams and and i'm thinking
that's not a fair request you know they
met when they you know and she never
said ahead of time if we get married i
expect you to play on your softball
teams but here's the deal it's just an
example of of we we do this in spoken or
unspoken ways it's kind of like you're
my girlfriend therefore you should
you're my boyfriend therefore you should
you're my wife therefore you should
therefore that's why i call them
ownership relationships this is the
definition of a fused relationship i
don't have all these other things out
here filling my bucket up so therefore
you should and you better because i've
given up all these things to be in a
relationship with you that i did have
when we met i'm even emptier now than i
was so i expect even more you should
fill me up and they're not the same
person that they were when you met
you're not the same person so we've
increased the odds of this not working
well by giving up the things we did have
in our life so to answer your question
when when i was doing marriage therapy
almost religiously in the first session
with the couple i would tell them
usually before the end of the session
the best thing both of you can do for
your marriage is develop good same-sex
relationships the guy needs to have good
guy friends the woman needs to have good
girlfriends now what i found working
with a lot of nice guys is a lot a lot
of men at work but don't have many good
guy friends and i tell men having good
guy friends is the foundation that
you're going to build a healthy
relationship on with a woman and so what
happens is they meet a woman and they
make her their best friend and they you
know want her to be everything for them
and many women do the same thing as well
so yes i agree that the best thing we
can do with our marriage in the
beginning is if we don't have them
already develop good relationships now i
i take this seriously i mentioned i've
been in a men's program for three years
i've been married to to my present wife
a little over four and a half years
she's mexican we live in mexico
um she doesn't speak english i've had to
learn spanish in my 50s and 60s my step
kids don't speak english even though
they're supposed to be learning and um
so here i am
kind of isolated you know because my
spanish has gotten better but i'm not
i'm not fluent mexican style fluent i i
can't swear as good as the average
mexican uh even though my wife does
their best to teach me um and i didn't
have many guy friends down here um you
know i'm now raising kids again i work
at home
uh my gym is in my house you know so
yeah i i just didn't have many male
connections and i knew
i knew the well-being of my marriage was
dependent on me having good guy friends
and so i was actually in work leading a
workshop talking about this cooperative
reciprocal relationship idea and had
some handouts that i was working with
the guys and i told them one of the
things i need to add to my list
that i need to add to my list of
cooperative reciprocal relationships is
a men's program i need to be with met
and then when i got done one of the guys
in my program said robert i'm in a men's
program you know we meet two or three
times a year for retreats we meet online
it's really great and he told me who the
coach was and who he trained with and i
loved the guy that he trained with i
said i'm in and so i joined three years
ago i'm about to start my fourth year
every year there's about 35 to 45 of us
we have retreats and wow it's just
blessed my life and it's improved my
marriage and it's made me more grounded
my my wife has either met or gotten to
know a number of the men that i know
some have been to my home you know if
i'm on zoom talking to them i'll say
come on come here say hi to you know
this particular friend um and so
me even in my 60s still trying to bumble
my way through through marriage and
relationship i just know if i don't go
spend time with men if i don't have the
support of men if i can't be revealing
myself to men
i'm gonna go downhill and my marriage is
gonna go downhill with it so yes i agree
with you we need good same-sex friends
and we need to take the focus off of our
partner that he or she should always be
there to meet all of our needs they
can't
okay
robert
thank you very much for coming on i
asked about
two of the questions i had i had a whole
list of them
that was very very interesting
that was very interesting thank you if
people want to follow you
or find out more about you where should
they go
just drglover.com
is to find everything i've got if they
if they google my name or google no more
mr nice guy i've got all the top spots
but yeah doctorglover.com and
yeah come find out who i am
okay well thank you for coming on
you're welcome thanks for the invitation
this was fun
[Music]